- It's been such a part of
my life for like six years.
- It just feels like a big
chapter in my life is closin'.
- It's changed so many people's lives.
- Without the show, I probably
wouldn't of ever come out.
(music)
- Two years ago,
my friend said, "Oh, why
don't you watch this TV show?
It's called Orange is the New Black."
And I was like, "Oh, no."
- Some really cool lesbian friends of mine
had an Orange is the New Black party.
And I thought, "It's got
loads of lesbians. That's it, I'm sold."
- I've taken days off work,
so I can sit and binge watch.
- I felt every range of emotion.
- Laugh, cry, love.
- I actually remember shouting
at the TV. - It is hard to
watch some of those scenes.
- I couldn't stop laughing.
I was like at the edge of my seat.
(music)
- You see these like characters
and they're so brave.
- There are just so many
strong women on there.
- You just wanna be the same.
- Taystee's my favorite.
She's just really, really funny.
- I don't even know who to choose.
- (blows air)
- Probably Poussey.
- Alex, she's my girl.
- It was interesting to
see the strong black women
similar to me on screen.
- Nicky, I can relate in that
falling for straight women
is never really a great idea.
- (laughs)
- The first time I watched it,
I enjoyed it as a show.
After, when I realized
that I am gay,
and then when I came
back to watch it again,
I actually felt a deeper
connection to the show as a whole.
- I told my family I relate to it.
And then I think that made
my family sort of realize,
like, "Yeah, she's obviously gay."
(music)
- This show is a vehicle for
a really strong political message.
- To see same sex relationships on screen
definitely like opens up a conversation.
- Usually, minorities in TV,
they just seen us just one dimensional.
- If we feel a little bit discomforted
I think that's the point.
- It showed mental health in a
completely different way.
- That should be normal.
Until that is the situation
progress will need to be made still.
(Orange is the New Black melody)
- I will be remembering this
for a long, long time.
- The show has defiantly
changed my perceptions.
- It makes me feel like I'm not on my own.
- It's one of the most pioneering shows
for and about women.
- The final episode,
yeah that's gonna be hard I think.
- It has made such a big mark in my life.
It's gonna be hard to let go.
- It's gonna leave such an impact.
Although it's sad,
it just means I can
start from the beginning
and watch it all over.